Are you sure I got it all head's kinda small. Okay.
How're we placed in terms of the alright.
We're okay?
Guess I should probably try to sit up straight.
Like that? Okay, cool.
We're good?
Oh, I think mine's fallen off.
It fell That's why.
I guess it's gonna be hard to drink coffee. Mm. Uh okay.
Ah.
Okay?
Right, so I'm just gonna start this PowerPoint real quick. Yeah, PowerPoint. Yeah, well, you know,.
Wow.
Very official.
Yeah I kinda like this I'm kinda getting into it. Right. Um. So just to kick off the meeting basically um so we're working now for a real
reaction, this is uh so it right. Just got an agenda to set out what we're gonna try to accomplish in this particular first meeting. Um We're gonna
just do a quick opening and we can hopefully all get acquainted with one another um then we're gonna start talk a little bit about tool training. Essentially that means
getting used to the only thing that we haven't tried out yet, the whiteboard. Um we've got a general plan for the project how we're gonna go about accomplishing
this and then just a bit of discussion close up. Um I guess you know game or something um in real life um so yeah basically I want to I'm
just gonna you got of course you can discuss that, I'm thinking about um uh proposing that since we've got this weird blend of ourselves and our roles that we
just don't ask, don't tell. Um so um if you say something about marketing, right, sorted, um y is Exactly. Um I mean obvi if
You're just gonna believe me, we'll go from there. Fair enough.
if you guys if if at the same time if you like logically if something doesn't like if I'm like we're gonna sell a remote control that's the size of this
paper book you know um you say like well that doesn't seem like such a good idea because of X_ obviously go with it. I mean we'll discuss it but
I'm not gonna ask do you know that or uh yeah it seems like yeah yeah exactly so, 'cause we're what we're sort of role playing is y g yeah
Prove it yeah, okay.
you're gonna tap into your own knowledge as well um. And that's the same for your when we do introductions I mean um and you talk about your background you
know have fun, you know maybe you went to um uh you know maybe i you're like in Maine you went to U_C_S_B_ but you wanna say you went to
Harvard or something like that, why not, you know you can this is you know I guess we can have a little bit of fun with it. So
are you guys okay with that does that seem logical?
Oh yeah, that's fine.
Sure.
Works for me.
Sweet.
Cool. So I guess that that we're totally we're making a remote control which is thrilling um uh but the idea is that we can make something based on the
Right.
whole corporate model I dunno if you guys had time to check the in real life I dunno if you guys uh checked the um uh the corporate website. Um
we've got to make something as fashionable as possible, that's kind of the corporate strategy is we're gonna try to take ordinary stuff that nobody really thinks about and try
to make it nice you know like John Lewis nice or you know if you go to Debenham's or something. So um basically we are reinventing the wheel but we
wanna try to do it in a user friendly um slick sleek kind of way. Um way we're gonna go about doing that is basically at first we're gonna start
on the basics. And that's where I'm gonna need you guys the User Interface Designers and the um um the other designer that I can't remember, the the I_D_
and the U_I_D_ right um the Industrial Designer hey right on alright, getting into it um to guide me and guide us on this project 'cause you're gonna be you're
Mm.
There you go.
g you guys are the bottom you know you're like no you can't do that you can't have you know X_ and Y_ um at the same time. And then
um we'll work up from what is necessary to more like what would be good, you know like um I I think you guys probably got the same emails I
did but the idea of um, yes a coffee pot needs to be able to hold coffee but it's also better if it's not like really cheap glass so that
it if you touch it you hurt your hand, or something like that. Um and so we'll work up from there and um then we'll meet on and talk
about it and then finally we'll incorporate as kind of the last stage you know where you guys build or tell me tell us what's possible and then you tell us
what we can um hope for and what way to go take the the the take the basics and make it nicer and then ov obviously uh the U_I_D_ and the
I_D_ you know you you can keep on the you know sort of at the cutting edge of how to get about maximising what is possible um to try t of
sync it all up. So that's the detailed design. So it's a three stage kind of thing. Um right so for now just for th the white board
um basically uh just to get used to it, I haven't tried it yet either um I'm just gonna start and um mm carry like five remotes around um and
just write down I'm just gonna write down one of the names of my um desert discs you know if you if you were trapped on a desert island and you
could only bring five C_D_s along with you name one of them that you could, not all five, if you wanna write all five go for it but name
one of them that you could um. Oh, we skipped introductions. Nice. I'm a excellent Project Manager. Um. I'm Marty, um I went to
uni at uh U_C_ Santa Barbara and I'm here working on a P_H_D_ in psychology. Um yeah. So
I'm Sarah, I went to Michigan, and I'm here doing cultural studies and I'm the Marketing Manager or something. Marketing, yeah Expert. Expert. Fine.
Expert Don't play yourself down. Expert
That's me.
I'm Ron. I uh once upon a time studied in Victoria and I am the User Interface Designer.
I'm Nathan, I'm from California, and I'm here doing a Masters degree in social anthropology. U_C_L_A_. Yeah. Okay.
Where did you go to uni Nathan? Oh brilliant. Cool. My little brother goes there. Right so desert island discs. Yeah.
So.
So do we have to wait for you to write it down or are you gonna tell us? I'm waiting to know.
Well I'll t i no no yeah I'm just gonna write a couple of 'em down. See I'm a big music fan I don't know if you guys are,
Uh
I'm assuming everybody likes music to some lesser or greater extent but there's some other options, if you're a T_V_ slut like I am like Smallville terrible television show but
Fair enough.
Oh, Smallville. I went to high school with Tom Willing actually. The guy. Yeah.
I happen to love it, it's rubbish but I love it.
T the the main c the main character? Wow. Is he a wanker?
Yeah. Very much so. Hell of a soccer player but a total bastard nonetheless. Yeah. He is a big guy. Yeah.
He looks really tall, like he's gotta be like six six. Yeah. Um okay so I really like Jeff Buckley. You guys heard of Jeff Buckley?
Mm-hmm.
Um that's cool 'cause like not very many people have. Um and um oh well I might as well throw a British person in there um you can't go wrong
with Radiohead. It's a r
Good call.
Okay so it really works just like a pen only makes noises I think. It's kinda weird. Anyway yeah. Yeah, you're like press and it's. Kinda
Interesting.
cool. You'll see. Alright so um whoever wants to get up next, you can write down some telly that you watch or whatever you want. Right on
I guess I'll go next then. Okay. Don't wanna lose all my mikes, plugged in here. Okay. This is basically just pen practice huh? Okay
Go for it.
.
W
. Oh you're much taller than me so I'm gonna write down here.
Um.
Right now I'm listening to a lot of somebody nobody's ever heard of, Chris Bathgate, local Michigan folk singer, really lame and uh uh what else did I
Mm.
Nice.
Wow.
bring with me? Probably classical, to totally geek it out, yeah I think.
Okay yeah yeah.
And my family guy D_V_D_s but we don't need to write that one down. So yeah. No. Are you getting it online, or is it on sky
Well yeah. Oh, family guy. Isn't h has h do you watch the new season?
I think I'm gonna start downloading it yeah.
? Yeah, that'd be nice.
Alright. Think I'm just gonna put down one uh one C_D_.
Anybody? No? no? Afro beat orchestra, very cool. Yeah. Fift S they like fifteen members from Brooklyn. Um and I'm hoping to go to
Mm-mm.
No.
'Fraid not.
Afro beat orchestra? Very cool. Mm.
Mm.
Sounds nice.
the concert in Belgium, in Brussels in April first. Yeah. It's supposed to be in Brussels anyways. Um thing I love about Edinburgh
Wow.
Exciting. That'd be.
Oh. I didn't even read those. Oops. I shouldn't admit that.
That's what a PowerPoint presentation is for. It's they're designed specifically to ignore. I it's th brilliant.
Oh, wow.
Yeah. It's the five by five, I can't read that much.
Ah yes yes yes okay I see that. Vomit. Yes. Street pizza. It's so brilliant.
Yeah oh it's so horrible.
Love um
I've seen more urine in this city than ever before, I mean
Oh my God. Seriously?
I just came from Glasgow and I'm um happy to say that there's the there's the same quantity approximately. Um. I w
There's more vomit there.
It's so minging. Uh.
It really is
Does uh yeah. Ready? Minging? Nice.
Alright. Yep.
Yeah. Slide it in there. Yeah.
I'm going local. Going local. I have to be here for three years so I might as well get the terminology right.
Yeah fair enough. I've already got more than I can keep track of. And I'm gonna go home next week and everyone's gonna be like oh my God you're
turning into one of those people, no.
Oh, have you been home yet? They'll be like, say something British, and you're like oh shut up family.
I know. I know. Oh it should be interesting. Wait until I tell them I'm not coming back. They're gonna love that one.
Uh-huh.
Um
Let's see.
Right you s you're gonna stay here? Wow.
Probably. Or at least get a work visa for a while and then decide. 'Cause nice. Of course. Oh, now I can think of so many
Bad religion?
Nice.
Yeah, that's the music I grew up listening to.
Yeah yeah, yeah.
And so there
other ones. That's how it works.
Well yeah that's why yeah.
Something I miss about my hometown.
I miss coffee. Burritos.
Burritos that cost less than eight Pounds. I grew up in San Diego, but yeah um La Jolla, P_B_. But really uh I last lived in San
Mm. Oh
Nice.
Oh yeah two two bucks. Where are you from in California by the way? Did you really? What part?
Any thing that are like free.
Yeah I'm from San Diego as well.
Nice.
Yeah oh man.
Francisco, I haven't lived in Cali well I haven't lived in southern California since I was eighteen.
Going to s like North Carol I'm sorry you you just can't get a better burrito than what's available in the s in San Diego.
It's different. 'Cause in San Diego th the tortillas are cooked on the grill and in northern California they steam them.
It must make all the difference.
Yeah, it really does.
Well it's it's i there's other things too there's you just can't place it like I when I went to school in the U_ in Santa Barbara which is central California
Ah.
the Mexican food is okay, it's just not good like and yeah it's like two bucks, like literally two bucks for this massive I miss yeah good call on
Mm.
Right.
that.
Yeah. Where you from in San Diego?
Mm.
Um just literally just metropolitan San Diego, I live like five minutes from the zoo. So North Park actually if you want to get real specific.
Okay.
Yeah, my grandparents lived on um thirty second.
Yep.
Close t uh do you know where Clare de Lune coffee shop is, and Cafe Forte
Yes. On university, yeah. Yeah it's actually like literally half a mile from my house. Yeah, pretty cool. Small world as we were discussing before
Cool.
Yeah.
. Especially when we're all from the same general region. Right so okay, success on the whiteboard. You can harness the awesome power a little bit introductions we
There you go.
Wow.
talked about some of our C_D_s and things we like about the city you know, I think we'll Um right so moving on to not fun stuff uh project finance
. Um basically what we're trying to do is sell this remote for twenty five Euros. Um. This is what the finance department has told me, the C_F_O_
but I don't know, I'm not sold on this, it's pretty dear, I mean twenty f that's like you know forty bucks for a remote. It would
have to pretty much like do my laundry for me. Um so what we can maybe work on that a later but we're gonna make a lot on it,
Mm.
the profit aims to make fifty million Euros on it. Eur internationally. So um one of the things I I was gonna mention to you um you guys the
designers is that um it m we probably need a rever it needs to be a universal remote control probably. Um so something that could do N_T_S_C_ as well as
Okay.
Makes sense.
PAL as well as various other formats like if it's gonna control D_V_D_s but um you know I'll leave that to you guys but that's something that i i it is
Uh.
gonna be an international sold thing. Um but we wanna try to make it for twelve fifty. So we wanna try to make a hundred percent profit on it
if we can. Um s right so um just to close up, I'm not sure how much time I've used mm next time right Project Manager, sorted.
Um. Is uh we'll meet in another half an hour or so um and I'd like the um Industrial Designer to get ge think about what needs to be done
, like what the basic function of it. Um U_I_D_ well yeah you right g your assignments are up there and you'll also get s assignments from in your email
as well more spec specifics on what do do. Um mm basic and um so I need you to tell us what um we what the user's gonna want.
What they're looking for.
So actually in a way you guys c maybe in our next meeting chat a bit about what the user's gonna want and what the user can have, you know
like uh so yeah well it is and we'll discuss the trade-offs in between um so yeah specific instructions will be sent in your email. But I think that that
And negotiate that. Uh.
is more or less a good place to start for now um and as more things come up we'll have meetings and you'll get emails and so forth. Um any
questions, before we get started?
I assume that we're building a stand alone uh remote control, we can't kind of build it into other uh products.
You mean to like
For instance like a mobile phone or something like that.
Mm. Sounds interesting.
Hmm.
Yeah.
I don't think there's any rules about it yet. So
Maybe our personal coach will have something to say about that.
Yeah.
Or or you know can we produ can we sell a remote control phone for twenty five pounds or less?
Well, have a think about it. I mean I'm I'm certainly op it seems like yeah it it seems like it's certainly do-able isn't it. I mean um
Mm.
Yep. Okay.
W yeah.
or if we can't have a full mobile phone maybe a remote that has some other kind of useful function. The clapper. No I mean no, good idea
Mm-hmm.
Yeah.
, good idea. We'll see what see what
Maybe a remote with changeable faces, like the faces that you can buy for phones. Yeah.
I like the little cover thingies.
Nice. Hot.
Uh-huh y I like that Yeah. That's true, I guess we we probably have some time, maybe we should brainstorm a bit like what we wanna do,
go back to um
I don't really have any. Let me bring up something about our basic goals here, what we want to accomplish. Uh project announcement.
Ts ts ts
Yeah. Not so much.
Hmm.
All right we'll find them, we're on our own.
Now are we also discussing kind of our initial ideas at all here?
Yeah yeah let's do it, let's do.
S does anybody have any initial ideas?
I'm gonna go ahead and take notes on this too 'cause
Good idea. Start your minutes. Um
Yeah I mean oh yeah right. So initial ideas.
Well it's pretty much given it's gonna be universal right, we decided that already and it may be functioning for other things, as soon as you said that I
Yeah.
was thinking like all the other things you could get a remote to do, like your microwave or your front door or like to have everything on one thing,
but then, I've never been a fan of those huge remotes that have like a million buttons, you can't tell what they do. Yeah. Specific.
S smaller's better. Simple.
Mm-hmm.
But I'm thinking I'm thinking kind of P_D_A_ uh design so touch screen design rather than button so that you can kind of flip around all sorts of different things.
Okay. Interesting.
Oh right. That'd be different.
Yeah that's slick isn't it. I mean like stylist yeah like a just a yeah. Right so we got five minutes more to chat about this, perfect.
True.
Um so we've got this kind of an idea of a trade-off between um uh size and functionality. Um and we also
Mm.
Mm. Right. We want it to be munt multifunctional but at the same time if you get it to do too much you're not gonna be able to tell
Yeah. It's gonna be too complicated, too crowded with buttons and things.
Too confusing.
them apart, that whole yeah.
I'm also gonna note for future reference this idea of um so you like maybe like an L_ like a touch screen type of remote?
Hmm.
Mm-hmm. Possibly.
Mm. An interesting option. Yeah. Definitely.
I don't think one exists. Be a good idea.
Needs it needs one outstanding feature to set it apart from all the other remotes.
Yeah all the other universal remotes. Um I don't know if there's such a thing out there, I guess we could do some uh do some research on or
one of us could do some research on it about whether or not there are um multi-format like um you know PAL, N_T_S_C_, region one
Right.
I'm pretty sure there is. I mean I I have a friend who has a P_D_A_ that he just points at his telev any television he wants and it'll figure
Okay.
That
Yeah.
out the the specifications of it and will control it um so I th I assume that that can be done with uh kind of around the world.
Interesting. Okay.
Awesome.
Yeah.
Okay. Okay.
Um all right. So. I li I'm liking that idea, this idea of a touch screen remote with multi-format features. Um.
Mm-hmm.
Right.
Um.
Let's see.
I think, making it out of a nice material would be very important, because so many of those remotes that you see, these universal remotes look so cheap
Yeah.
and low quality.
Mm.
Yeah. Keeping it nice and slick, would be important. And I don't know, like, there's such a problem with losing them, that adding this whole
like P_D_A_ pen business is only one more thing to lose, so we're gonna have to be careful with what like
Mm.
Oh.
Just something like keep in mind when we start actually dealing with this stuff but that would be really cool.
Uh let's see. Um.
I like the idea of the uh multi plate. In in
Yeah yeah okay.
Yeah. Fi b like what are they called, those face plate things? Isn't there a name for them? Are they? I dunno.
Think they're just called face plates? I don't know.
something, uh we'll have to come up with a name, patent it.
I like. We should c we should come up with a fuzzy one as well. For those cold winter days.
Yeah. Something really cool.
Leopard print or something.
Leopard print.
Um.
Hmm.
I think, it wouldn't be such a bad idea to have a like a locator device, maybe a simple button that you have on your television to help you
find your remote.
True.
Mm. But if we're bundling it unless we're selling their telly with the remote. Um
Right.
Mm.
Well if we bundle it as a phone then you can always call it. If you're not doing that then we can have something that just kind of rings from
True.
either well there used to be those whistling devices but that's a little bit annoying.
Right.
Cou could we not do something where like just a little lit like literally just a very small kind of thing that comes with the remote that you could place something
else that you press and it makes the remote page. Kinda like how on a lot of um uh cordless regular phones, you have a page button and it
Th
Right.
Yeah.
goes, could we do something like that?
Right.
That's cool.
I think so. Yeah.
Probably.
I think we could design into that.
Good.
Um yeah I think this material quality as well like I guess what we can think about what kind of um uh you know Apple 's been really successful with this
Mm.
surgical white kind of business or this sleek kind of you know
Yeah. And that titanium the new silver sleek ones that's last couple of years, very much so. Mm.
Mm.
Yeah.
Curves.
Yeah. We do have the minimum am amount I mean we were talking finances I dunno, selling a a forty Pound remote would h or a forty Dollar remote
, twenty five Euro remote would be pretty you know it's pretty expensive so maybe we might wanna trade off some of the features for a lower price. Without without
Right.
getting into that whole like you know go down to bargain store remote you know bargain store universal remote that's black and you know m massive, some kind of I
Yeah.
Mm.
dunno a balance there in somewhere. But um have a think about what we can do, have a think about what we want to do, how we're gonna
Definitely.
Yeah. Or if you our users in mind, like these grandmas are not gonna be into this whole new let's design, no it's they're used to the buttons
sell it and um
so we'll have to be careful of exactly who we're marketing this to, and who we're gonna be able to get it out of.
Yeah.
Mm.
'S true.
But
We're talking twenty five Pounds or twenty five Euros?
Twenty five Euros.
Euros.
Slight difference I guess.
Yeah. They're all weaker than they're all stronger than the Dollar. Although, computer parts, all if you're gonna upgrade your computer, buy it in the States
Mm.
. Like um do you guys know Fry's? Huge computer uh electronics store? They serve um right they sa tha s they will sell things overseas so you can
No.
Mm-mm.
Mm.
buy stuff in America and have it shipped over for like twenty thirty Pounds about. Right so um let's go ahead and wrap that up here for now, I'm
gonna put these initial ideas that we've got in the um project documents, so if you guys wa need a reminder about what we've talked about um the different you
Okay.
know kind of trade-offs that we've got and the other ideas, you can consult them at your leisure. And uh right so thanks for that. Let's just uh
head back to work on what we were talking about bef uh goi h h getting into.
With half an hour?
Um. Yes. Thanks guys.
'Kay. Perfect. Cool.
Thank you.
Alright.